for more on this let's bring in former
acting dhs secretary chad wolfe great to
have you i want to show you a couple of
numbers here
so cbp customs and border patrol had
1763 unaccompanied migrant children in
his custody as of tuesday
625 of whom had been held more than 72
hours i i think that's going to be
another
issue right because there is this issue
of how long you can hold them
is going to come up
well absolutely i think the numbers uh
across the border whether it's single
adults whether it's families or uacs are
up across the board
and particularly uacs are troubling
because you can't release them
you can't do the catch and release like
you can with the family units and the
single adults that we see that the biden
administration is doing
so what does that mean you have to hold
them in border patrol facilities and
then you have to hold them in hhs
facilities
and what happens when you have so many
is it starts to back up and i think
that's what we're seeing now and so
you're you're seeing kids held for
longer than 72 hours which is really the
the top limit of how long they should be
held in border patrol facilities which
are essentially
jail like settings you need to get them
to hhs
so that they have a more appropriate
setting but at the end of the day you
need to send the right message
and the wrong message is currently being
sent to the traffickers the smugglers
and others that now is not the time to
come
there is a time to come it's just not
now and that message is too nuanced
they're not going to get it and you're
seeing the numbers just increase across
the board
dana mentioned that some of them are
wearing t-shirts that's an extraordinary
thing is it not
have you seen that before they're
wearing t-shirts let us in
i i have not and i think what it tells
you is that the advocacy community there
are ngos and others
that their entire goal is to make sure
that anyone that shows up at the border
gets into the united states and is able
to stay
perhaps for years and years regardless
of whether they actually have a
legitimate asylum claim or not and i'm
sure that these types of organizations
are providing these t-shirts to these
folks
trying to send a political message and
trying to play
politics with the safety and the
security of that border
i'm really interested in the cartel
angle and what we do there there's a
sheriff in arizona named
mark daniels he's in cochise county and
he said we
just built roads for the cartels
think about that
yeah absolutely i know sheriff daniels
pretty well
and a lot of the law enforcement
community along that border are seeing
firsthand the results
of what we have seen over the past four
or five weeks and there are going to be
the ones that are going to have to deal
with the increase in illegal
apprehensions
the public safety risk and everything
else that goes on in those communities
and you see that when border patrol is
overwhelmed state and local law
enforcement are going to have to step up
but i think it's important to note
there's not one individual that has
smuggled across that border comes across
that border illegally does not paying a
cartel
a trafficker or smuggler to do that and
so essentially the biden administration
is fueling more and more cartels
making them more profitable because each
and every person that they send across
that border
is money in their pocket that's an
extraordinary thing to say the
administration will not call this a
crisis
yet maybe that changes what would you
call it
oh it's absolutely a crisis i mean when
you start building tent facilities
hhs facilities and dhs is certainly
looking at facilities dhs is redeploying
officers from the northern border to the
southern border
you have uh you know comments about
they're working 24 7.
all indications is it's a crisis
everyone knows it's a crisis they need
to be honest with the american people
uh and certainly those communities along
those borders are experiencing an
influx of individuals that are likely
going to read historic proportions
in the next several months all right
chad wolfe always good to have you
as we continue to follow this story
we'll be on top thank you